foreign
welcome to this video on the natural
language processing engineer NLP
engineer roadmap by simply not to stay
updated with our content make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon so in this video we will
Begin by examining the role of NLP
engineer progressing further our Focus
will shift toward the Essential
Knowledge and Skills required to excel
as an NLP engineer having
comprehensively explored these subjects
we will then proceed to explore the
intra CC and constructing of a
professional career roadmap dealer
specifically for individuals aspiring to
become accomplished NLP Engineers on
that note if you are an expiring AIML
engineer then there is no better time to
train yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
code that covers everything from the
fundamental to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Caltech program
partnership with IBM this AIML bootcamp
in collaboration with Caltech will help
you advance your career as AIML
specialist the AIML bootcamp includes
live classes delivered by industry
expert Hands-On lab industry relevant
projects and master classes by Caltech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course includes 222cus
from caltex ctme online convocation by
Caltech ctm program director simple and
career service helps you get noticed by
top hiring companies on a bootcamp
certificate from caltex cdme industry
relevant project in three domains
Caltech CDMA Circle membership 25 plus
Hands-On project across industry
verticals with integrated Labs so why
we're join now seats are failing fast
find the course link from the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
NLP engineer an Azure language
processing NLP engineer is a
professional responsor for crafting and
constrainting computer systems that can
process SS and produce human-like
language NLP branches out into numerous
captivating domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech recognition the reach of NLP
extent across a diverse spectrum of
application notably featuring virtual
assistant chat Bots sentiment analysis
customer service interaction and
language translation the task of NLP
engineer involves interacting these
Innovative application and seemingly
embedding them into the existing
framework
the average salary for NLP engineer in
India is 10 lakh per year and in the U.S
average annual salary for NLP engineer
is 120 000 so moving forward let's see
skills required as an NLP engineer so
becoming an NLP engineer entails the
acquisition of a diverse set of
application and knowledge some of these
encompasses first one is Proficiency in
programming Mastery of at least one
programming language such as python Java
or C plus plus coupled with the solid
graphs of data structure algorithm and
principle of software engineering the
second one is grasp of machine learning
building a strong foundation in machine
learning algorithm and composing both
supervised and unsupervised learning
familiarity with Advanced Techniques
like CNN and RNN is vital the third one
is NLP technique cultivating a deep
understanding of NLP techniques which
encompasses facets like text
pre-processing synthetic and semantic
analysis and intricate domain of
sentiment analysis the fourth one is NLP
libraries and Frameworks navigate easily
through NLP libraries and Frameworks
such as natural language toolkit and ltk
speci Stanford's code NLP and gen Sim
harnessing their capabilities to
streamline your NLP Endeavors the fifth
one is data science Acumen developing a
sound gaps of data science principles
and combusting facets such as data
visualization statical analysis and the
Art of data manipulation armed with
these multi-phase skill set you will be
primed to embark on a journey as an
accomplished NLP engineer ready to
navigate the complexity of natural
language processing and contribute to
the exciting world of NLP Innovation
going forward let's see the professional
NLP engineer roadmap here is a
comprehensive professional statutory for
those aspiring to become NLP Engineers
the first one is Educational Foundation
embargo your journey by pursuing a
degree in competition Fields such as
computer science Linguistics or
artificial intelligence many
accomplished NLP Engineers hold Advanced
degrees either a master or PSD in these
domains the second one is internship or
entry-level Venture considering
immersing yourself in Practical
experience through internship or entry
level job within the industry these
opportunities not only keep with the
Hands-On expertise but also Aid in
constructing a robust portfolio the
third one on the list is skills and
knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of essential
proficiency requests of NLP engineer
this encompasses programming processes
and machine learning and NLP techniques
and data science the fourth one is
portfolio development curate a diverse
portfolio teaming with projects that
illuminate your capabilities and
expertise projects like suffocated
chatbot a sentiment analysis tool or a
language model can sustain your aptitude
for solving real world NLP challenges
and validate your skill set for
potential employers the fifth one is
networking underwears engage in
conference meetups and industries events
to force connection with fellow NLP
professionals the sixth one is
specialization consideration point under
the prospect of specialization in
specific NLP realm be it machine
translation speech recognition or
conversational agents this
specialization not only differentiate
you in the job market but also enables
you to attain expertise within a
particular niche in summation the part
about becoming an NLP engineer enters a
fusion of educational attainment
hands-on experience and the Mastery of
electric array of skills and knowledge
domains and with that we have come to
end of this video on NLP engineer
roadmap I hope you found it valuable and
entertaining please ask any question
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problem thank you for watching stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here